And six ultrasound panels done on swollen lymph nodes in my groids, armpits, and neck looking
for residual cancer last week.
The scans came back as oversized nodes in groids, but the conclusion was benign in all,
well, praise God for that.
The oncologists want to biopsy the nodes in the groin in the armpits.
If not cancerous, the oncologist wants to do surgery of my neck and remove the lymph nodes.
As a precaution, and to test them, what are your thoughts?
Well, in one sense, I would agree with your oncologist that, well, we don't know until
we get a complete pathology report, maybe we take the tissue out and spit it onto a slide
and look for cancer cells.
There could be cancer cells there, but what are we going to do to remove all your organs
to do that same thing?
Well, you have to draw the line somewhere on how invasive you want to get.
So if not invasive tests show a low possibility of cancerous tumors there, then I would be
inclined to just say, okay, let's not to get too cut happy.
Zero lymph nodes, they can be, so lymph nodes can enlarge when you're dealing with an infection.
Lymph nodes can enlarge when you're dealing with a lot of toxins.
Lymph nodes can enlarge when you're dealing with a lot of things that are going through them.
So what goes through the lymph nodes?
Anything that's cleared out of the tissues upstream from that lymph node.
So things don't get cleared out of the tissues magically.
They have to go through your open-ended lymph papillaries.
So your lymph vessels pick up fluid and waste in the tissues and it drains down back to your
venous system, which then goes through eventually the liver again and it's detoxified through
the liver detox pathways.
So that's how we get toxins out of our tissues, whether those toxins are from things that we're
exposed to topically or whether things that get dumped from the bloodstream that we ingested
or from surgical procedures that were distilled to that lymph node.
Chemical procedures like chemotherapy that have to go through that, all those kind of things.
So I mean it's up to you, I know there's a lot of people in the world that they just will
just do everything that their oncologist says because they think that's the best chance
to survive.
They'll just go and have all those things removed and some people may, I'm not saying some
people don't have good results with that but there's a lot of people that have bad results
with that too.
I think you have to make the decision to draw your line and have some sense of conservativeness
in allowing the next procedures.